this great big story was made possible
by the Singapore Tourism Board hip-hop
is the truest representation of who you
are and waveform
I grew up experiencing this beautiful
duality of Tamil and English Tamil is
one of the five most commonly spoken
Indian languages Tamil is a huge part of
who I am and when I chose to pursue
music I could not do it without petal
being in the picture my name is Yong
Raja I'm a Singaporean rapper I rap in
English and Tamil W the Crippler water
do something in flipping the dollar
super money my family moved from South
India to Singapore in 1992 growing up I
spent most of my time thinking in tempo
and writing in Tamil for me it was an
idea mixing the Tamil that I know how do
we put that and English into the
equation of hip-hop that was the
question that I was trying to solve the
first ever experiment we did or was to
make a remix of no pumps or Gucci game
and we called it poori game and puri is
a very famous Indian dish and that was
very well received the blend of Tamil
and English is just seamless you don't
feel like I'm mixing another foreign
language
cause wanna see something really
interesting has been happening recently
with the world of hip-hop you see people
like rich Brian you see people like
higher brothers that pursue hip-hop and
rap with their mother tongue there's
something very unique about this because
Asian hip-hop I think is so so beautiful
you are adding another language that
carries so many stories so much history
so much heritage to this life that
changes the game
[Applause]
this is the greatest thing about hip-hop
when you let people know where from and
what you stand for and what you
represent people respect you peace it's
a boy yeah I'm Raja
you